foreign
do I dare ask what calamity must have
transpired to bring you home to me do I
dare ask why this series keeps telling
us and showing us that big things are
happening but everything feels so small
and unimportant super squirrels any
chance I could Super Skip these
previously on segments every week Ron
this is not running this is writing just
gonna go ahead and start my countdown
timer for when guy inevitably comes back
to life and go
called it you know for a spy show this
has been remarkably predictable also man
Khaleesi had it easy when her boyfriend
slash murderer died we had to wait an
entire year to figure out if he'd come
back to life and now I'm remembering
season 8 of Game of Thrones so here's
two extra sins for that an episode of a
television show set in 2012 does not
contain a John Cusack episode believes
we need to see every single step Nick
Fury takes in this restaurant to get to
the spot where he can hang his coat and
we do not as I was watching all the news
coverage of those guys heroics over in
the states strangest thing thinking that
putting your newspaper articles in
French will keep our American speaking
writers from finding a way to sin it but
you overlooked the keys in which is the
French language because if he's the man
I think he is he is a power powerful
sense of righteousness I don't know if a
righteous man would remake hydrotech to
be used in his own organization but what
do I know I'm just the narrator for a
YouTube channel dedicated to sin
righteousness is a little scarce around
our office good book it's a collection
of poems so no Raymond Carver
you familiar yeah
more of a history guy myself thinking
that literature written in the past is
not part of History he's known for his
brevity
[Laughter]
yeah all three hours and eight minutes
of the very talky shortcuts would very
much like to enter this chat and what
did you want to call myself beloved roll
commercials Fury was fired a couple of
days ago speaking during any kind of
Fine Arts performance those choir kids
have likely rehearsed for months for
this one concert wait until intermission
to talk to your neighbor do they not
have performance etiquette on scrollos
before it was destroyed I ddt'd that
dude from the top rope it was like
Undertaker level DDT was actually a move
created by one Mr Jake the Snake Roberts
Undertaker did become famous for the
tombstone pile driver which honestly
would have been more fitting to use for
your bullsh wrestling metaphor you enjoy
this concert leaving before intermission
which is yet another violation of
concert etiquette I've already taken
care of her did you though did you not
notice her body missing the next time
you left the compound this is why you
double tap graphic I should never
ever have
forced you into this and I am sorry the
thing Emilia Clarke's agent said to her
after watching the series somehow made
it into the episode and we have a big
bargaining chip do you though wouldn't
the bargaining chip be taking this
danger to the president and saying
you're the only one who can fix it if
you've already stopped the crisis you're
dispensable the president doesn't need
you anymore and you've lost your
leverage we just keep contributing show
them our hearts they will see us
oh wait he's serious
Gaia would be scrotastic at TV since
oh I get it because everyone in the
series is wearing a mask subtle Marvel
but I won't send you for that what I
will send you for is making this lack of
subtlety into creepy home decor
nobody would willingly hang this on
their walls nobody up by far
are you including that time you held an
agitated alien cat up to your face and
lost an eye don't do that Nick hey
remember that scene of Captain Marvel
where Nick Fury said even his wife and
kids would call him Fury yes that was a
lie so here's a sin for lying that I
would never hurt
well that was an unrealistic promise
even for someone planning to kill their
eventual husband nobody goes an entire
relationship without hurting their
partner even accidentally part of having
a relationship is acknowledging when you
up apologizing and learning to move
past it together I'm starting to think
skrills don't watch Dr Phil and what did
you want
tell myself beloved callbacks to events
that happened less than 12 minutes ago
I'm not sure if this means we should get
divorced
or we should renew our vows Nick Fury
clearly went to the rail and given
School of relationships they'll be
coming for you I'm a big girl I could
take care of myself yeah because why
would Fury want her to come with him and
they could help each other stay alive I
mean that's just silly right
I honestly can't figure out if this is
supposed to be a surprise for the
audience or not we've already seen the
scroll impersonating Roadie talked to
Priscilla in the church learn how to
actually surprise people before you just
start going willy-nilly with twists in
your episode that's all I ask well that
and to make a show that is actually more
interesting than this one memory serves
I should can do into Oblivion a few days
ago firing someone doesn't prevent them
from randomly reappearing in your life
dude when Jeremy fired me I stalked him
relentlessly until he agreed to start TV
since and let me narrate it just to
leave him alone we I wanted to share my
favorite liquid lunch with you liquid
lunches that just spells I don't think
you can successfully Gaslight Nick Fury
twice eventually he's gonna catch on he
ain't stupid aside from that cat scratch
thing I mean I guess maybe I could buy
that Roadie was able to keep this
footage out of anyone's hands but there
were several people at this fight and
presumably more than one person who
would have witnessed what appeared to
Nick Fury committing murder so the idea
that this incident has not already
leaked outside of this room is a lot of
is that really what you're
gonna go with at your trial seems like
it'd be pretty easy to prove just
introduce talos's evidence well we
literally had a shape-shifter
impersonating a judge in She-Hulk did
you forget that I mean I know some
people try to forget that show before I
have you to finish traded making your
audience Google the Finish trade instead
of just saying toss you out a window
oh man looks like gravic used those
missiles that only make Vehicles flip
over instead of blowing up tough break
my man oh well you'll remember that for
next time I'm sure villains pull up in
matching black fans so we know that
they're villains cliche
if you have these abilities why wouldn't
you lead with him instead of firing guns
why did graphic change back to his other
human form after being shot instead of
reverting to a scroll form like Talos
did the graphic give himself the
superpower of convenience
oh no not Talos yeah I don't give a
another word
[Music]
is it safe it's catching a little bit
today you don't get to joke not today
I just took a bullet for you and what
did you want to call myself beloved I
like turtles that's bad
and that's you listen everyone knows
when you make an assumption you make an
ass out of you adoption liquid location
tracker microchips in your bloodstream
allows it to track your movements in the
field hope you had a restful flight
Weird Al Yankovic is on the plane
pregame for our bilateral with the
Russians or the half bottle of bourbon
I'm not drunk wait I am drunk
oh my God the quarterback is toast